Luffy might be in trouble.
Bevause, as the One Piece manga is quickly
reaching the end of the Egghead Island Arc,
and this chapter just gave us hints of how
the final battle is truly going to play out.
Which includes the POWERHOUSE MATCHUPS including
Gear 5 Luffy against the Shadow Clone Jutsu
Admiral Kizaru, the Awakened Lucci versus
Zoro, and Saint Saturn against probably everyone
else.
But that’s not all because with most of
the major characters coming together on the
bottom part of the island whatever climactic
event we were promised is surely about to
blow up and turn this arc into the match that
sets the final saga burning.
But first we just have to talk about Luffy
versus Kizaru because as I hoped the marine
admiral is not just going to be completely
overwhelmed by Gear 5 Luffy.
In fact what I NEVER EXPECTED was to see Kizaru
bust out the Shadow Clone Jutsu and make clones
of himself in order to take out Luffy.
In fact, up to now he honestly seems completely
unfazed by Gear 5 Luffy, apparently being
the only person to be fully resistant to Luffy’s
cartoon powers and even easily outsmarted
Luffy by distracting him with the clones.
Not the first time we’ve said Luffy’s
been outsmarted, but it makes me wonder if
we, and even possibly Luffy, have been underestimating
Kizaru a bit.
I mean this man is a marine admiral who confidently
asked if he should go to Wano to handle Kaido
AND BIG MOM so maybe we should be wondering
just how desperate this situation is for Luffy
and
the crew.
And while we
will discuss more about the fights in this
chapter in just a moment, first I do have
one major question about Kizaru’s new clone
powers.
I mean we have seen many devil fruit users
create clones before like when the string
fruit user Doflamingo made a clone to tank
this hit and we’ve Nico Robin make tons
of clones that she can control, but both of
these characters ate Paramecia type devil
fruits which allow them to control the substance
they produce.
But that is not the case for Kizaru and as
far as we know Logia fruits have only ever
been able to shoot out their elemental abilities,
not really control them.
For example, the lightning fruit user Enel
could launch massive bolts of electricity
and admiral Akainu can blast people’s faces
off with his magma fists, but creating separate
clones that can act on their own?
That is something we have never seen and I
am SUPER CURIOUS what level of control Kizaru
has over these.
For example, is he somehow controlling the
light?
Or are they independent beings that can act
on their own?
Or are they just light projections kinda like
the holograms we saw earlier in this arc?
Plus we have to ask how this is even possible
in the first place since we have never seen
it before.
Maybe it is some form of awakening or is it
just some special ability on his light devil
fruit?
I honestly cannot wait to find out.
Now despite how incredibly cool Kizaru looks
showing off even more of his awesome abilities,
I have to say that I am actually pretty disappointed
in the direction this fight seems to be taking.
Because it seems that Kizaru is not 100% interested
in fighting Luffy.
Instead, he keeps going after his different
objectives, like when he tried to attack the
Vegapunks last chapter and in this one.
Likewise, Luffy is busy trying to protect
his friends instead of going all out against
the admiral.
Which, by the way, that shot of him taking
in Kizaru’s light and splitting it like
some kind of prism was just awesome.
But besides that I am just getting a really
bad feeling that this fight is going to end
with the straw hats and some allies escaping
instead of the all out fight that I was personally
hoping for.
However, this might actually be a good thing
because we definitely won’t be getting a
long-drawn out fight like we would expect
from a major battle.
Need I remind you of the forty-nine chapter
marathon like Luffy versus Kaido?
And ultimately this means we should be getting
to the promised epic finale even faster.
There is still plenty of fighting going on
in this chapter though and in particular one
MAJOR CLASH is Zoro against the fully awakened
leopard fruit user Lucci.
And I’m honestly SUPER EXCITED to see how
Zoro stacks up against the government secret
agent.
Because if Gear 5 Luffy absolutely destroyed
Lucci, then Zoro’s performance against Lucci
should give us a good idea of how current
Zoro compares to Luffy.
Of course we do have to consider the small
chance that Zoro loses this battle, but honestly
I would be SHOCKED if that were to occur.
Even in his awakened form, I don’t think
Lucci is stronger than Kaido’s right hand
man, King, and if you remember Zoro basically
one-shotted King once he finally learned how
to control his advanced conqueror’s haki.
Although Lucci is probably more of a backstabbing,
ruthless fighter than King, so who knows maybe
he will use some dirty tricks instead of fighting
Zoro in a true one on one?
And while we’re speculating about the future,
this is the perfect time to recap the possibility
of the Vegapunks leaving the island with the
straw hats.
In fact, in this chapter Jinbe can even be
seen taking a bunch of Vegapunk’s gear towards
the Thousand Sunny, so it seems like a pretty
strong theory that at least one of the Vegapunks
will be coming along.
And in case you forgot, here are the latest
updates on all seven Vegapunks.
We know from chapter 1090 that Shaka and Pythagoras
were confirmed to be dead, although you know
how that goes in One Piece.
Will of P and everything.
Then we have the bite-sized Edison who is
still in the control room with Nami, Usopp,
and the traitor York.
Next is Lilith who is currently piloting Franky’s
giant mech carrying the straw hats ship to
the back of the island.
And that just leaves Atlas and the main body,
who have driven this awesome “Vega Tank”
all the way to the battlefield to order the
Pacifistas back to their side.
With all of them scattered around it is still
really hard to tell how many, if any, of these
Vegapunks will survive.
Though if I had to bet I would guess Lilith
will be the one to go with the straw hats,
since she is the one who has been with the
ship all this time.
But I simply cannot go any longer without
sharing this AWESOME theory about the main
Vegapunk which actually makes A TON of sense
for the epic finale for the end of this arc.
Hear me out…
Because as we’ve discussed before, the Egghead
island arc has parallels to many previous
arcs, but one connection I have not heard
discussed as much is the similarities to the
island of Ohara which we saw during Robin’s
flashback.
On that island there was a ton of information,
such as research into the poneglyphs, that
the World Government didn’t want anyone
to share with the rest of the world.
So let’s bring this back to Egghead now,
we have the reverse situation where Vegapunk
has A TON of top secret information that he
most likely doesn’t want to fall into the
world government’s hands.
On top of that, he also knows about the poneglyphs
and the ancient kingdom.
So I can just imagine that as the straw hats
escape, the main Vegapunk does two things.
First, he sends out information about the
ancient kingdom to the entire world, completing
the work that was started at Ohara.
He could probably do this using Punk Records,
which is kinda like the internet.
Second, I can very easily see Vegapunk pushing
a self-destruct button or something to destroy
Egghead island just like the World Government
destroyed Ohara.
He would probably do this to prevent the World
Government from getting their hands on the
Mother Flame energy source that they need
to power their super weapon that can destroy
entire islands.
And if this sounds too crazy for you, remember
that Vegapunk installed a self-destruct button
on his previous lab on Punk Hazard, so it’s
actually not as insane as it sounds.
And that mind-blowing situation is exactly
what Kizaru and Saint Saturn would want to
avoid.
Because although this would most likely accomplish
their goal of killing Vegapunk, it would mean
their other two main objectives of obtaining
the Mother Flame and rescuing York are probably
ruined.
Who knows maybe Saint Saturn might even be
caught up in the explosion which would be
a huge shock to the world.
But speaking of Saint Saturn, his brief appearance
at the end of this chapter hopefully means
that he will soon be joining the action.
Now what will this man be doing?
Well, let’s break it down because no matter
what way you look at it, he ABSOLUTELY MUST
be a part of the epic conclusion that we were
told would end Egghead Island.
The first and most obvious thing he can do
is retake control of the Pacifistas after
the Vegapunks took them over in this chapter.
Which by the way, I have to ask where are
the Seraphim at this point?
I know they were locked up in bubbles a few
chapters ago, but wouldn’t it make sense
for them to join the battle if they are commanded
by Vegapunk?
Or maybe they should stay locked up in bubbles
to keep them from flipping sides AGAIN.
And honestly I hate to add onto the negative
takes in this review but, I am starting to
get pretty tired of this whole Seraphim and
Pacifista flipping sides thing.
Because when these Warlord clones were introduced
there was SO MUCH hype surrounding these characters.
BUT all that hype is absolutely gone at this
point because one chapter they are our allies,
then in the next they are enemies.
I mean yes they are super strong, but then
they were also taken out in one go by bubbles.
Yeah…
Although the one side of this that I WOULD
LOVE TO SEE is the Seraphim somehow managing
to gain control of themselves.
Which totally fits with all the talk in recent
chapters about being slaves to the government.
For example, Kizaru feels like he has to follow
orders and Kuma used to be a World Government
slave.
So wouldn’t it be great if the ones who
literally have to follow commands could somehow
break free?
Whew.
Anyway, rant over.
Subscribe to the channel.
And let’s get back to Saint Saturn.
Now it should be easy for him to command the
Pacifistas because of the command structure
we were shown earlier in the arc.
But besides that I NEED for Saturn to show
off the mysterious powers that we first saw
in chapter 1085.
Because in case you forgot, Saturn appears
to have this bull-like transformation with
these giant horns.
Now we don’t know if this is a devil fruit
power or something else, but I just have to
learn more about it.
And what more perfect time than the end of
this arc when there is sure to be a massive
conflict.
Speaking of that conflict, Sanji might actually
be the first one to face off against Saint
Saturn because he is currently with the main
Vegapunk and the Pacifistas.
So how will Sanji respond to seeing the Elder
Star?
Will he jump straight into an attack or will
he be busy fighting the Pacifistas?
Or will someone else come and make a mess
out of this fight as well?
Honestly, this would be the perfect time for
the Blackbeard pirates to make their appearance.
Although it would also be the perfect opportunity
for them to go after the rubbings of the Poneglyphs
on the Thousand Sunny, since it is only protected
by Lilith and Jinbe at this point.
Or an even crazier option would be if someone
like the marine hunting organization Cross
Guild showed up and truly shocked the world
by taking out one of the Gorosei on their
own.
Man, THAT.
WOULD.
BE.
INSANE!
Plus it would give us the chance to see Luffy
and Buggy reunite.
Which honestly I love these two together SO
MUCH that I made an entire video explaining
how stupidly powerful Luffy would be with
a second devil fruit, including Buggy’s
surprisingly overpowered Chop-Chop fruit.
And if you want to see just how insane it
gets with some of these wild combinations,
you can watch that video right here.
Shanks for watching and I’ll see you in
the next one.